لقد كان القط والفأر بين الشرطة
والمتظاهرين هنا في Champs
Elisa في وسط باريس ،
كان المتظاهرون يركضون في الشوارع
ويطلقون عبوات الدخان عليهم ويطاردونهم ،
إنه وضع متقلب يستمر في
تحريك الشرطة لديها المئات
والمئات من الأجهزة المحمولة
ضباط يرتدون ملابس الشغب هنا ، بعضهم دراجات نارية ، والبعض الآخر
على الأقدام ، والبعض الآخر في شاحنات صغيرة ، إنها
ليلة محورية بالنسبة لفرنسا الليلة إذا
انخفض العنف مقارنة بالأيام الأخيرة ،
فربما يكون أسوأ ما في الوضع
قد انتهى ، لكن في الوقت الحالي ، هذه محاولة
لإبقاء المحتجين.  الذين كانوا في
الغالب في الضواحي والمدن الأخرى
خارج شوارع The Prestige في
وسط باريس ، إنه مزيج مجنون هنا من
سائحين من باريس ،
صحفيو شرطة مكافحة الشغب فقط أناس خارجون لرؤية
ما يحدث ، لكن الأمر متقلب عندما
تحرك الشرطة هم بروك  تحرك هذه النهاية
ودفع الناس بعيدًا عن الطريق